what we are going to do in this video is
talk about the idea of power when we are
dealing with significance tests and
power is an idea that you might
encounter in a first year statistics
statistics course it turns out that it's
fairly difficult to calculate but it's
interesting to know what it means and
what are the levers that might increase
the power or decrease the power in a
significance test
so just to cut to the chase power is a
probability you can view it as the
probability that you're doing the right
thing when the null hypothesis is not
true and the right thing is you should
reject the null hypothesis if it's not
true so it's the probability of
rejecting rejecting your null hypothesis
given that the null hypothesis is false
so you could view it as a conditional
probability like that but there's other
ways to conceptualize it we can connect
it to type two errors
for example you could say this is equal
to one minus the probability of
not rejecting one minus the probability
of not
rejecting
not rejecting the null hypothesis given
that the null hypothesis is false and
this thing that i just described not
rejecting the null hypothesis given the
null hypothesis is false this is that's
the definition of a type
type
2
error
so you could view it as just the
probability of not making a type 2 error
or 1 minus the probability of making a
type 2 error hopefully that's not
confusing so let me just write it the
other way so you could say it's the
probability of
not
making
not making a type
type 2
error
so what are the things that would
actually drive power and to help us
conceptualize that i'll draw two
sampling distributions one if we assume
that the null hypothesis is true and one
where we assume that the null hypothesis
is false and the true population
parameter is something different than
the null hypothesis is saying
so for example let's say that
we have a null hypothesis that our
population mean is equal to let's just
call it mu
one
and we have an alternative hypothesis
so
h sub a
that says hey no the population mean is
not equal to
mu 1.
so if you assumed a world where the null
hypothesis is true
so i'll do that in blue so if we assume
the null hypothesis is true
what would be our sampling distribution
remember what we do in significance
tests
is we have some form of a population let
me draw that
you have a population right over here
and our hypotheses are making some
statement about a parameter in that
population and to test it we take a
sample of a certain size we calculate a
statistic in this case we would be the
sample mean and we say if we assume that
our null hypothesis is true what is the
probability of getting that sample
statistic and if that's below a
threshold which we call a significance
level we reject the null hypothesis
and so that world that we have been
living in one way to think about it in a
world where you assume the null
hypothesis is true
you might have a sampling distribution
that looks something like this the null
hypothesis is true then the center of
your sampling distribution would be
right over here at mu1
and
given your sample size
you would get a certain sampling
distribution for the sample means
if your sample size increases this will
be narrow or if it decreases this thing
is going to be wider and you set a
significance level which is essentially
your probability of rejecting the null
hypothesis even if it is true you could
even view it as and we've talked about
it you can view your significance level
as a probability of making a type 1
error
so your significance level is some area
and so let's say it's this area that i'm
shading in orange right over here that
would be your significance level so if
you took a sample right over here and
you calculated its sample mean and you
happen to fall in this area or this area
or this area right over here then you
would reject your null hypothesis
now if the null hypothesis actually was
true you would be committing a type 1
error without knowing about it but for
power we are concerned with a type 2
error so in this one it's a conditional
probability that our null hypothesis is
false and so let's construct another
sampling distribution in the case where
our null hypothesis is false so let me
just continue this line right over here
and i'll do that
so let's imagine a world where our null
hypothesis is false
and
it's actually the case that our mean is
mu 2 and say let's say that mu 2 is
right over here and in this reality our
sampling distribution
might look something like this for once
again it'll be for a given sample size
the larger the sample size the narrower
this bell curve would be
and so it might look
something like this
so in which situation so in this world
we should be rejecting the null
hypothesis
but what are the samples in which case
we are not rejecting the null hypothesis
even though we should
well we're not going to reject the null
hypothesis if we get samples in
if we get a sample here or a sample here
or a sample here a sample where if you
assume the null hypothesis is true the
probability isn't that unlikely and so
the probability of making a type two
error when we should reject the null
hypothesis but we don't is actually this
area
right over here
and the power the probability of
rejecting the null hypothesis given that
it's false so given that it's false
would be this red distribution that
would be the rest of this area right
over here
so how can we increase the power
well one way is to increase our alpha
increase our significance level if we
increase our significance level say from
that remember the significance level is
an area so if we want it to go up if we
increase the area and it looked
something like that
now by expanding that significance area
we have increased the power because now
this yellow area is larger we've pushed
this boundary to the left a bit
now you might say oh well hey if if we
want to increase the power power sounds
like a good thing why don't we just
always increase alpha well the problem
with that is if you increase alpha so
let me write this down
so if you take alpha your significance
level and you increase it that will
increase the power that will increase
the power but it's also going to
increase your probability of a type
1
error because remember that's what one
way to conceptualize what alpha is what
your significance level is it's a
probability of a type 1 error
now what are other ways to increase your
power
well if you increase your sample size
then both of these distributions will
these sampling distributions are going
to get narrower
and so if these sampling distributions
if both of these sampling distributions
get narrower
then that situation where you are not
rejecting your
null hypothesis even though you should
is going to have a lot less area there's
going to be one way to think about it
there's going to be a lot less overlap
between these two sampling distributions
and so let me write that down so another
way is to
if you increase n your sample size
that's going to increase your power
and this in general is always a good
thing if you can do it now other things
that may or may not be under your
control
is well the less variability there is in
the data set that would also make the
sampling distributions narrower and that
would also increase the power so less
variability and you could measure that
as bivariance or
standard deviation of your underlying
data set that would increase your power
another thing that would increase the
power is if the true parameter is
further away than what the null
hypothesis is saying so if you say true
parameter
far
from
null hypothesis what it's saying that
also will increase the power so these
two are not typically under your control
but the sample size is and the
significance level is significance level
there's a trade-off though if you
increase the power through that you're
also increasing the probability of a
type one error so for a lot of
researchers they might say hey if a type
two error is worse i'm willing to make
this trade-off i'll increase the
significance level but if a type one
error is actually what i'm afraid of
that i wouldn't want to use this lever
but in any case increasing your sample
size if you can do it is going to be a
good thing